Edward lascare parents éloigné de
l'ancien Champion du Monde Emmanuel
askers s'est livré à la chasserole la
plus extraordinaire de l'histoire des
échecs tout commence dans cette position
par l'incroyable sacrifice de dames Tam
prend achète échec le roi noir est
obligé d'accepter l'offrande permettant
un double échec à la découverte si
monarque tente de se réfugier dans le
coin il est puni sur le champ par la
cavalerie blanche qui délivre un superbe
mataler tout fait
le roi doit donc s'aventurer hors de ses
bases et permettent une série d'échecs
qui commencent par cavalier G4 le roi de
la télé en G5 et là les pions sonnent la
charge H4 échec le roi franchi la
frontière G3 échec le roi poursuit sa
route fou et deux échecs le roi de la
s’abriter derrière les pions blancs tout
rage 2 échec le roi arrive jusqu'à la
case G1 première rangée adverse et il
est puni par roi des deux échec et mat
lascar aurait pu conclure avec panache
par grand rock là aussi échec et